you the floor you will prompt it on your
screen to unmute yourself
you would appreciate if you could turn
on your camera when you are asking a
question
today's briefing is being broadcast via
youtube and europe by satellite
the footage can be used free of charge
by all media
you will find the respective links in
the invite sent yesterday
i'm now handing over to mrs cook mrs
cook please
[Music]
thank you marianne yes and good
afternoon ladies and gentlemen and thank
you for joining this press please
briefing
our expert committee on the safety of
medicines the pharmacovigilance and risk
assessment committee has now come to a
conclusion
on the review of cases of blood clots
and people vaccinated with astrazeneca's
cobit 19 vaccine
the committee has come to a clear
scientific conclusion
this is a safe and effective vaccine its
benefits in protecting
people from covet 19 with the associated
risks of death and hospitalization
outweigh the possible risks the
committee
also concluded that the vaccine is not
associated
with an increase in the overall risk of
thromboembolic events or blood clots
now during the investigation and review
we began to see a small number of cases
of rare and unusual but very serious
clotting disorders and this then
triggered a more focused review
based on the evidence available and
after
days of in-depth analysis of lab results
clinical reports
autopsy reports and further information
from the clinical trials we still
cannot rule out definitively a link
between these cases and the vaccine
what the committee has therefore
recommended is to raise
awareness of these possible risks making
sure that they're included in the
product information
drawing attention to these possible rare
conditions and providing
information to healthcare professionals
and vaccinated people will help to spot
and mitigate any possible side effects
we're also launching additional
investigations to understand
more about these rare cases and were
conducting
targeted observational studies
over about seven million people have now
been vaccinated in the eu with the
astrazeneca vaccine
and 11 million have been vaccinated in
the uk
in the uk and there is increasing use of
this vaccine in other countries
it remains very important that all side
effects are closely monitored and
reported
so that we can evaluate them and see if
there's any need to update the
information and warnings about
possible risks dr straus will explain
the committee's evaluation in more
detail but i want to reiterate that our
scientific position is that
is that this vaccine is a safe and
effective
option to protect citizens against covet
19.
it demonstrated that at least 60 percent
efficacy in clinical trials in
preventing
coronavirus disease and in fact the real
world
evidence suggests that the effectiveness
could be even higher than that
we're very much aware that some member
states have paused vaccinations
waiting for ema's outcome of a review
but given that thousands of people in
the eu die
every day and in fact over
2500 were reported one day last week it
really was crucial for ema to review
rapidly and thoroughly all the available
evidence
so we made this review our highest
priority
and our experts have worked intensively
to analyze in great detail all the data
available
we have mobilized european experts in
the field of thrombosis and blood
disorders to investigate and we work
closely with other health authorities
across the world
including with the uk's mhra
the scientific conclusions adopted today
provide member states with the
information they need
to take an informed decision regarding
the use of the astrazeneca vaccine
in their in their vaccination campaigns
before i hand over to dr strives i would
like to highlight
that a situation like the one we have
just seen here is not unexpected
when you vaccinate millions of people
it's inevitable that rare
or serious is instances or illnesses
will occur
in the in the time immediately following
vaccination
our role in the eu regulatory system is
to rapidly
detect these incidents and investigate
whether there may be a link to the
vaccine or whether they are a result
the result of illnesses which occur by
chance close in time to the vaccination
we are committed to ensure that any new
suspected adverse reactions are rapidly
investigated to support decisions based
on science
which can then support competence in
vaccines which is so important in
dealing with this
devastating pandemic that we are facing
and we remain
fully mobilized to to ensure our public
health role
today's conclusion helps us to continue
in the fight against this pandemic by
raising awareness
and providing up-to-date information as
we can
as we have analyzed it and as uh and as
as it becomes available so that so that
citizens across
europe are informed about what they need
to do thank you very much
thank you very much miss cook and now i
hand over to dr strauss dr strauss
please
thank you very much mariacnes and good
afternoon
the pharmacovigilance risk assessment
committee prague
that i chair has looked in great detail
at the cases of blood clots reported
after vaccination
with covet-19 vaccine astrazeneca
as soon as these concerns arose last
week the committee started a
comprehensive review
of all the available evidence and
working around the clock
making use of all the resources at our
disposal
i want to thank the colleagues from the
belgium team that have led this
assessment
and worked side by side with colleagues
from national competent authorities
and the european medicines agency as
well as scientific experts in blood
disorders
who we asked to provide advice in the
assessment the prague has come
to the following conclusions this
vaccine is safe
and effective in preventing covet-19 and
its benefits continue
to be far greater than its risks
proc has found no evidence of a quality
or a batch issue the committee has
assessed
and discussed pre-clinical and clinical
trial data
published literature and adverse events
related to the blood clots that have
occurred during the vaccination campaign
reported by vaccines and healthcare
professionals
critical to the review has been the
careful scientific assessment
and clinical scrutiny of the individual
cases
from the different member states prague
noted
that the number of thromboembolic events
reported after vaccination
is lower than the expected in the
general population
and proc has concluded that there is no
increase
in the overall risk of blood clots with
this vaccine
moreover because the vaccine is
effective in preventing covet 19 disease
which in itself is a cause of blood
clots
it likely reduces the risks of
thrombotic events
overall however there are
also still some uncertainties we have
seen some very
rare case reports describing specific
unusual events of a combination of
thrombosis
and thrombocytopenia and bleeding
in a few cases tiny clots developed in
multiple blood vessels
in the first 7 to 14 days after
vaccination
a condition called disseminated
intravascular
coagulation also in a few cases we saw
clots developing in blood vessels
draining blood from the brain
and this condition is known as a
cerebral venous
sinus thrombosis these conditions
are linked to low levels of blood
platelets also known as thrombocytopenia
and the evidence we have is at the
moment
not sufficient to conclude with
certainty whether these adverse events
are indeed caused by the vaccine or not
so prague will continue to gather more
information on these conditions
including additional studies and prague
will keep them
under very close monitoring prague also
concluded that it's very important that
these events are rare
as of last night seven cases of this
disseminated
intravascular coagulation and 18
cases of cerebral venous sinus
thrombosis
were reported out of almost
20 million vaccinated people
furthermore certifications were not
identified in the large clinical trials
but that highlights the importance of
being vigilant
once the vaccine is administered to
large populations
prague felt also that it is of great
importance that healthcare professionals
and people coming for a vaccination are
aware
of these possible adverse events and
that they can spot
possible signs or symptoms that may
occur after the vaccination
therefore prague has recommended to add
a warning
to the smpc and the patient leaflet
and the description of these cases
so that this information should be
provided to healthcare professionals
and to the public ema and national
health authorities will ensure
that health care professionals and the
general public
are made aware of this information and
made aware of the signs and symptoms
of concern so that timely action can be
taken
to mitigate these risks and with that i
would like to hand back to murray agnes
many thanks dr strauss we are now going
to open the floor
for questions only to remind you if you
wish to ask a question please click on
the raised hand icon which appears when
you move your mouse
over your name in the participants list
in webex when i give you the floor
you will be asked on the screen to
unmute yourself
and you can then start by stating your
name and
affiliation so let's see who is
already who wants to ask a question
so far i don't see anybody
do we have any questions
okay there i see gabriel zany
so please gabrielle can you ask your
question annuit yourself and start your
camera please
okay hello everybody gabriel zany
italian tv la 7 broadcast
piazza polita um well
do you think that the application of the
principle of precaution by more than 15
states like germany france italy etc
risk to become a greater damage going to
undermine the trust
of the population in astrazeneca vaccine
perhaps i can ask mrs cook to respond to
this question
mrs cook yeah thank you very much for
the question
i think a lot of member states are
waiting for this
outcome of the safety review and this
they have indicated to us that what ema
has done from a scientific perspective
is very important for them to
to make a decision on how to continue
with the vaccination so we are
delivering on that promise
today and our responsibility is
to come to a conclusion as to whether or
not
the benefits outweigh the risks of the
vaccines
so that countries can make an informed
decision
and increase trust in the vaccine
many things so the next in line is susie
ring from bloomberg
susie please go ahead
hi there um could you just clarify if
there is any link found between these
cases and the vaccine
what further steps you may take would
that result in another label update or
any other outcome
and could you also give some specifics
around what kind of a label update we
might see is it just related to these
specific conditions or general
information about blood clot awareness
many thanks susie i would ask dr strauss
to respond to this
sabine yeah thank you proc has concluded
that there is a proposal to update
section 4.4 that it's the warning
section of the summary
of the product characteristics and in
addition
also the patient leaflet but because
this is of course
a very special situation prague is also
discussing
tools and means to reach out to the more
general public
and also a dear healthcare professional
letter which is a term
to be used for information that's being
sent to healthcare professionals
all over europe in order to make them
aware of this additional information
and to help them to mitigate the risks
in case patients
might suffer from these signs and
symptoms and we also highlight to all
the
population that's being vaccinated to
what symptoms and signs they should look
out for
in order to be on time if they develop
something that might indicate that there
is blood clotting issue
many thanks dr strauss i now give the
floor to
tom clark from itv tom please
tom do you hear us
we see you but we don't hear you
can you open up your mic
okay let's perhaps first take another
colleague and then we come back to you
tom yeah if that's fine
okay so i take next joe barnes joe
please
obviously more people have connection
problems today
oh joe i see you can you talk
you want to ask your question
do you hear us
obviously we have a connection problem
here i'm sorry for that
because um i get the message from many
journalists that they don't hear us
so no they don't you don't hear us at
all
no obviously not
sorry colleagues we are looking into the
problem
have they heard what we've said so far
and the response to the first question
questions
[Music]
i think so because they have then asked
questions we would have heard before if
they wouldn't have heard us you know
they would have told us
so let's uh try uh with the next
journalist uh
roland termotta from the standard can
you hear us and can you ask your
question
i can hear you and i hope you can hear
me yes all fine thanks a lot
okay because the connection dropped i'm
not sure whether this question has
in the meantime been addressed or not
but um so you
mentioned that the evidence that you
have at the moment is not sufficient to
conclude
with certainty whether these adverse
events are caused by the vaccine
these rare adverse events um could they
be caused by
something else such as acute infection
and which other
yes scenarios are you looking into with
regards to
two factors that may have caused the the
syndromes that we've seen
many thanks dr strauss can you take that
question
thank you we have been discussing quite
some hypothesis
to see what would be a an explanation
for these
cases and as we know covet itself
is an important risk factor for
thrombosis
and also a post-covet syndrome
we noted that often people are being
hospitalized with thrombosis in the
aorta
so it might be that that might have
played a role
but for the moment we still feel that we
see
a sufficient information to
include a warning in the product
information
and we will further investigate with
this scientific advisory group
with additional studies and maybe my
colleague dr peter arlett would like to
highlight
the other studies that we are planning
or the other investigations
that might provide a more definite
answer
many things so peter perhaps you can
complete
so thanks very much indeed um this is an
important
uh safety review and we need to make
sure that safety review continues
and that we continue to be driven by
science and have a fast
but also robust evaluation further
evaluation will include additional
expert advice
will include using epidemiological
studies so studies using healthcare data
from the real world
and we can use that to look at a
population level
as to what the levels of thrombose
thrombosis are
and we can also look at laboratory tests
to see whether there's anything
in particular about these patients that
are getting the
unusual uh blood clots that might
suggest or help us to understand the
the the mechanism for the clots
occurring thank you
many thanks for those additional
explanations dr arlett so i'll
give now the floor to jenny hill from
the bbc
jenny hello yes um from your initial
investigations
into these rare events is there any
suggestion so far
that specific groups of people might be
considered to be at
greater risk of a thrombosis event
dr strauss please thank you
yes the uh truck review of the cases
of thrombosis combined with
thrombocytopenia
has shown a predominance in some groups
and notably
in women and younger women of younger
age
however at the moment it's still rather
premature to conclude
on a very specific group because
the background risk of thrombosis may be
different
in this group but it may also be the
case that more people
have been vaccinated in in this specific
group for example reflecting a
predominance of younger women
and we know that in the different member
states different vaccination campaigns
have uh been going on so the potential
for
a different risk levels is being part of
the further evaluation
like highlighted before and if risk
minimization options are identified
this will of course be further
communicated
many thanks i am now taking a question
of ole alexander sauer
from the afton post in norway ole please
hi can you hear me yes he can hear you
yes perfect um yes i'm ul alexander from
norwegian often boston
um how do you assess today's report from
oslo university hospital has have you
taken that into account
i'll give the floor to dr strauss
well we have assessed everything that
was available to us
up until yesterday because we have of
course a report
available for the full proc to be
discussed
so if there is a report that has been
come out today
that has not been included but what has
been included
is the specific cases that we have
received from norway and these have been
discussed in depth
and also a norwegian is represented
is represented in the uh pharmacovision
risk assessment committee so in that
respect we have taken everything on
board
but if there is a study that has been
published today
then we have not taken that on board yet
but it will be part of our continuous
monitoring of these issues and we will
need to come back to these issues like
we highlighted before
anyway so this is a preliminary
conclusion
on the specific cases so it will be part
of our further research
for sure thank you many thanks i now
give the floor again to tom clark itv we
couldn't hear your question initially i
hope this time it works
tom please hello hi can you hear me this
time
yes go ahead thank you the signal drops
out there for a bit thanks for coming
back to me i do appreciate it
um two questions one a um a technical
one first
you mentioned you had 18 cases of cbst
and seven cases of another phenomenon i
didn't quite
follow your description of it could you
give us a little bit of a clarification
on that but secondly can you help
explain why we've seen
significantly more cases of these events
in
eu countries compared to in the uk where
we only have
five reported cases of cvst even though
twice as many doses of astrozenica
vaccine have been distributed here in
the uk
thanks tom dr straus
yeah thank you well um the ddic
disseminated intra vascular coagulation
is an um is a disease or a syndrome
where there is ves uh thrombosis so
coagulation
while at the same time the uh blood
platelets
and the thrombocytes um are depleted
and and and therefore you get thrombosis
in combination
with bleeding so it's a that's a little
bit of a further explanation of this
uh specific disease
and um it's at the moment it's rather
difficult to know exactly the reasons
why there is a difference in the cases
we're
working from spontaneously reported
cases
and what we know for sure is that the
populations that have been vaccinated
are very different
between the different member states and
between the the uk
that might be a possible explanation but
at the moment we're not sure how to
explain that
i don't know if doctor p arlett would
like to come in
dr aled if i was to speculate i think
the most likely explanation is
different populations being vaccinated
we know the astrozenica vaccine in the
uk
was given predominantly to older
patients and we know
compared to the totality of european
member states
and um therefore if uh
blood clotting disorders are more common
in younger women for example
then it would suggest that you would get
more cases in europe than you would in
the uk
many things so now the floor is
given to kaikupwashmit can you please
ask your question kai
yes thank you very much um first of all
i'd appreciate it if you maybe could
break down
um in terms of the the cases of dic
and and the thrombosis whether you could
say how many countries these are from
but mainly i wanted to ask when you say
do you see we've had this discussion in
germany of course also about
hemolytic remix syndrome there's you
know the complement system involvement
can you do you have any further ideas on
what exactly you know what exactly might
be happening
if indeed the vaccine were involved that
could trigger this
dr strauss please thank you yes i can
give you
a breakdown on the cvst as of
yesterday of course we have
seven cases from germany three cases
from italy
two cases from norway and one
from spain and we have in addition to
that
three cases in the uk and two from
india and as to i think it's a very
relevant question that you are posing on
what is exactly going on and that's
something that we are going
to investigate and explore further in
the near future with our
um advisory group with specialists with
hopefully
results from studies that will become
available but for the moment
it's all speculation so
thank you very much so next is jenny
strauss book from wall street journal
so there's a news conference from the
european medicine agency following their
review of the safety of the oxford
astrazeneca
vaccine their conclusion that the
vaccine is safe and effective
and that its benefits outrage outweigh
any
risks the vaccine is not associated with
an overall
increased risk of blood clots but the
european medicine agency said it
still cannot rule out definitively a
link between a small number of rare
clotting disorders
and the oxford vaccine and so it has
recommended raising awareness about
these risks to spot any possible
side effects let's bring in our europa